vuoi diventare una di noi
[Musica]
che cos'è questo beh potrei dubitare che
cos'è questo amore berlino quando
aspetti mani di sgranocchiare che c'era
l'armadio si no
i ricorsi sono cattivo ci siamo già
incontrati che ho fatto sparire monti il
cuore certo che mi ricordo ero chi è
bastato ma videogiochi da serpente
spaventosi al massimo visto nell'armadio
di chi erano
[Musica]
ma tu assomiglia a 930 niente materia
non voglio far arrabbiare e ora il
ministro bit dove ha fatti di me dove la
spesa era piccola
la fatina la sfera ma che cosa stai
dicendo io non ho visto nessuno fatica
conosco nessuna sfera al meglio non
conosco nessuno poteva non ho visto
nessuna spera a quel rumore no c'è
merlini che sta sgranocchiando il suo
ossigeno
ma perché sei venuta qui allora no
perché l'altra basta vi sono divertito
tantissimo trasformare la fatina in un
insetto ora intitola di formati quindi
deciso di tornare trasforma in un
infetto anche berlino si può trasformare
tutti per trasformare ho bisogno della
era piccola dimmi dove i vini dove la
matina la sfera piccola la fatina io non
l'ho visto fatichino a os x piccole boh
non lo so se sicura magari ti stai
confondendo sei non esisti ubicato a me
la famiglia è la fatina e lo faceva
uscita sai e penso che non riuscirai a
trovarla perché è uscita da da parecchio
tempo e guarda ma io ti consiglio perché
magari non torni da dove sei venuto
oppure ritardo nell'armadio fi
indicatissimo ne facciano un rumore che
non muore non sentito niente io cos'è un
uomo ti scordi non c'e nessuno non c'è
nessuno guarda non c'é nessuno qui ti ho
detto che sono da solo dormono non c'e
niente così velocemente
aspetta aspetta aspetta ti dico dove la
sfera allora la sfera
praticamente ti spiego dove siccome noi
avevamo molto paura di quella sfera che
abbiamo preso con una coperta
abbiamo fatto un buco in giardino
l'abbiamo l'abbiamo sepolta in giardino
se fosse giardino e si gode proprio
paura abbiamo paura e quindi abbiamo un
messaggino abbiamo preso con una coperta
per non toccarlo le mani la mia povera
[Musica]
chi disegna una mappa con il percorso da
seguire praticamente per andare
esattamente dovesse volta la sfera così
potrai scavare e trovare la trasfera va
bene si stesse si interfaccia dubbi
dovevamo qui facendo ci sta impiegando
un po perché la spadista mia brutta
precisa mano a chi mi guarda
ecco la mappa come non si capisce
tu sei qui ed evitare o fare devi fare
lo slalom tra gli alberi e poi
praticamente arrivi a questo punto e te
ne accorgi perché al terzo albero tra il
terzo e il quarto albero però sul terzo
albero c'è la pala per scavare quindi
così potuto tra il terzo al quarto
potrei scavare e scavando scavando
scavando potrei trovare la tua suo
forziere scusa non un forziere ho
sbagliato e la sera piccola troverai qui
va bene vado a prendere la mia
ma tu guarda qui chiudere oa chi ha 34
così sicura che luca palamara
dimenticare una mappa ma c'è chiuso
chiave qua dentro
sì sono riuscito a farle uscire vita può
uscire fuori adesso dai vieni ma sei
impazzito ma che resta di piano è questo
cosa c'è che non va nel piano che ho
fatto
se non riusciva a farmi allontanare
adesso possiamo scappare insieme un
piano geniale non distratta così noi nel
frattempo possiamo scappare
guarda come scava guarda come cosa c'è
che non va non appena scoprirà che la
sfera non è sotterrato in giardino
tornerà e sarà arrabbiatissima e che non
possiamo neanche scappare perché ha
chiuso la porta a chiave ha
effettivamente non ci avevo pensato noi
per caso una seconda chiave un'altra
chiave nascosta da qualche parte così
magari riusciamo ad uscire
no che non ho una chiave di emergenza
però ascolta o un piano mentre voi due
stavate parlando elaborato un piano che
spero tanto che funzioni per molto
rischioso forse abbiamo ancora del tempo
vediamo
per fortuna sta ancora scavando non ha
ancora scoperto la verità allora il
piano è questo sentire molto punto
rischiosa e abbiamo pochissimo tempo
quindi ascoltami bene se ciò che di più
lei
tra poco rientrerai sarà arrabbiatissimo
perché avrà capito che le imprese in
giro quindi
devi stare molto molto attento certo sì
sì sì ok ok il mio piano è questo
i predetti ce l'ho capita forse mi sono
sbagliato forse non c'è niente mi sono
sbagliato ti ho detto ti senti subito
un'altra mappa va bene
diventerai ceramiche
prendete di furbi che napoli mi ha
[Musica]
informato che avevamo le favole a farlo
bene ok non mi dici subito europei
cass
[Musica]
cosa hai fatto
dov'è finita la faccia cattiva e il
piano di cui ti parlavo ci sono riuscita
ora mettiamo a posto
[Musica]
l'unione peggio vita dentista fatta
cattiva ora stai cosa si prova ad essere
piccolo come un insetto come minimo è
ora sai cosa si prova ad essere
rimpiccioliti come un insetto ben detto
che mi pensi vuoi andare a fare
conoscenza con le formiche sì certo
ali con cui non posso nemmeno volare
infatti me lei donate solo per punizione
e manieri anche strappato una mi
dispiace per te fatta cattiva è giunta
la tua bene
[Applauso]
[Musica]
in effetti potremmo pensarci è sparita
mi sento molto meglio finalmente è stata
però io non mi fido molto della fabbrica
questo dice miniserie 36 giornata
normale ora liberatevi hai un'idea
un'idea ti guardo io
ecco qua negati questa patina come tutta
la dentro la prova ora tu a superare
questa prova fatina così per trattare
male le persone capito chi lo do a
minacciarci che è venuta un'idea sai
aspetto
[Applauso]
ora che ha imparato la lezione direi che
possiamo liberarla che ne pensi
i nostri tempi spetta liberarla forse no
potrebbe ancora essere pericolosa però
ora che ci penso è prova a non aver
paura
noi non abbiamo più paura di lei quindi
è vero non abbiamo più paura perché
l'abbiamo rimpicciolita quindi ce ne
possiamo liberare rimettendo nella
scatola da dove è uscita no non abbiamo
più paura di lei perché l'abbiamo
rimpicciolita dobbiamo rimetterla nella
scatola e vediamo se scompare chiudiamo
e aspettiamo control adesso vedi si è
sparita
il tiro un po di paura di aprire trovare
qualcos'altro tu che ne pensi merlino
non c'è niente
mi raccomando però non aprire mai più
quella scatola e non prendere mai nessun
oggetto da quella scatola ok me lo
prometti va bene te lo prometto
ma l'importante è che ora abbiamo vinto
[Musica]